the president's right Democrats they
spend every second minute hour of every
24-hour day looking to smear this
president I've said it before if he
cured cancer they'd still hate him and
yet it hasn't slowed the president down
has it in fact while Democrats were
always busy obsessing about the Russia
host the Ukraine hoax
Russia Russia Ukraine Ukraine impeach
impeach president well he's been hard at
work since he was elected and the
results they speak for themselves now
take a look at your screen these are
accomplishments this is just a side note
here of a president during the single
most difficult to hyper partisan time
moment if you will in our lifetimes and
through it all he has still been able to
remain focus on his promises the success
the track record is amazing we have the
best employment situation since 1969 in
less than one term yep watch what you
see there the president has renegotiated
trade deals with Mexico Canada Japan and
South Korea and of course the wall on
our southern border he's got the money
now it's getting built he ended more
bureaucratic red tape than the last 50
years combined he successfully pointed
to constitutionalist judges to the US
Supreme Court and hundreds of other
federal judges yes originalist
constitutionalist he passed the largest
tax cuts in history that generated an
economic boom we have nearly nine
million new jobs created nearly nine
million fewer Americans on food stamps
and millions more out of poverty as I
said the lowest unemployment rate since
69
most Americans are working today that's
nineteen sixty-nine than ever before in
history for the first time in decades
the this country now in 75 years is
energy independent and a net exporter of
energy the life blood of every economy
on this earth none of it matters to the
left none of it matters to their mob
friends in the media none of it from the
moment he entered office frankly the day
came down the escalator with melania
they called for his impeachment never
seen anything like this they did their
very best to defeat him
they even saved one his opponent from
prosecution
certain prosecution that we would have
been prosecuted for then of course the
dirty Russian dossier the very thing
they were accusing him of that he didn't
do they were guilty of it is a
never-ending unceasing and hysteria lies
hoaxes conspiracy theories and now it is
a real clear present danger to this
Republic remember Ben Franklin monarchy
or Republic a republic if you can keep
it I'm not so certain tonight we're
going to keep it we live in a country
now we're simple simple basic
fundamental facts objective truth basic
truth obvious truth the rule of law
constitutional governance is in jeopardy
tonight and the damage may be
irreparable and by the way now like
Groundhog Day here we are all over again
you thought it was over it's not Russia
Russia it's just Ukraine Ukraine for the
Democrats this has never ever been about
getting to the truth nor about serving
their constituents all this is about for
them as power and an inexplicable hatred
enraged towards Donald Trump all things
Trump remember what congressman Al Green
said in May Democrats don't impeach the
president well yeah he could wouldn't
he's likely to win re-election you know
pretty much sums it up the end goal has
always been impeachment there's no
actual path there's no crimes high
crimes misdemeanors abuse the power
bribery none of that so for the past
three years Democrats have tried they
have failed time and again to
manufacture out a whole cloth
impeachable offenses as Nancy oh we have
many options of many choices on
impeachment
well there's pick one and if there's no
quid pro quo we'll lower the bar the
Asteria
now surrounding Ukraine is no different
and today Congressman Devon Nunez I
think one of his finest moments in
Congress he summed it up perfectly let's
take a look I want to congratulate the
Democrats on the rollout of their latest
information warfare operation against
the President and their extraordinary
ability to once again enlist the
mainstream media in their campaign this
operation began with media reports from
Prime instigators of the Russia
collusion hoax that a whistleblower is
claiming president Trump made nefarious
promise to a foreign leader the release
transcript of that call has already
debunked that central assertion but that
didn't matter the Democrats simply moved
the goalposts I pay attention the media
mob will never report this here's what
we know about this so-called
whistleblower complaint the complaint
relied on no not a real whistleblower
hearsay evidence reports from the
mainstream media I guess anyone in
America can be an official government
whistleblower just have your friends all
get together and write it up in a really
lawyer leeway the Inspector General
determined that the whistleblower had a
political bias against the president no
shock there in fact he or she is
represented by a law firm that actually
pays for anti-trump leaking from the
government even have one of their
billboards I hear outside of Langley and
where the CIA is either way the
Department of Justice they investigated
the complaint didn't take him long to
determine zero crimes were committed
none zip zero there was no quid pro quo
the Ukrainian president even the foreign
minister both denying being pressured by
President Trump in any way Democrats
latest ploy impeached the president is
beyond a dud they see that guy there
he's the biggest liar in Congress his
name is the Cowardly shift literally
made up out of thin air he made it up
today
his own little version of the transcript
that we all read yesterday didn't matter
what what some non whistleblower
whistleblowers said but as we had the
information yesterday so all this all
whoa we got to hear the whistleblower we
read it yesterday and there was nothing
in there at all that they claimed would
be in there he performed a dramatic
reading shifted for all his adoring fans
back in California before I show you the
clip I want to make this clear what
we're gonna play you is not the
transcript between Trump and his
Ukrainian counterpart no that wouldn't
work that's called truth objective truth
know what he does is pure fiction this
is a Adam Schiff fantasy that he decided
share in today's hearing you know the
guy that was caught on tape literally
colluding with someone he Paul was a
Russian to dig up dirt from a foreign
government against Donald Trump watch
the liar in action this is the essence
of what the president communicates we've
been very good to your country very good
no other country has done as much as we
have but you know what I don't see much
reciprocity here I hear what you want I
have a favor I want from you though and
I'm going to say this only seven times
so you better listen good I want you to
make up dirt on my political opponent
understand lots of it on this and on
that the transcript was so damning why
did mr. Schiff either' had to make up
his own version that's right because
everything Schiff and his colleagues
accused the president of doing they
themselves are guilty that would be
called projection for example let's look
at the topic of collusion Democrats
falsely claiming over and over again the
president colluded with foreign
government well if that was really bad
it was actually Adam Schiff caught on
tape looking for naked pics is that all
naked yeah did fly to mirror see them
did a lot of mirrors see them
yeah but the course vitamin C the naked
pictures Trump yeah he got nailed by two
pranksters that said they were from
Russia and he was trying to get dirt on
Donald Trump to impact the elections
from a Russian and in 2017 in early
January that year political they issued
a damning report we've reported it I
don't think the mob has about the DNC's
real Ukrainian collusion Democrats cared
about Russia collusion why did they care
about Ukrainian collusion look at
politico's it's a thirty two minute read
according to their estimates ukrainian
government officials tried to help
hillary clinton and undermine trump by
publicly questioning his fitness for
office they also disseminated documents
implicating a top trump aide and
corruption and they suggested they were
investigating the matter only to back
away after the election and they helped
clinton's allies that's right
literally DNC operatives that sought
information from
foreign country to help impact the
election to get damaging information on
Trump and his advisers they did this
with the help of a highly paid DNC
operative that would be called real
collusion any hysteria and he calls for
investigation nope this is a political
game only if you can bludgeon Trump is
the name of the game don't care about
real collusion don't care about quid pro
quos just look at sleepy creepy Joe 303
303 rias trouble tonight over what are
legitimate credible claims that he
leveraged the billion dollars in
taxpayer money now maybe if he called
and said can I talk to you as a father
well maybe that would have been
different but he used our money to get a
Ukrainian prosecutor fired who was
investigating his son and even the New
York Times warned him and he tried many
times to get this guy fired and
eventually succeeded when he said you
got six hours o son of a B they fired
him according to multiple sources as
Evatt as vice president 2014 Biden was
appointed point person by Obama in
Ukraine few months later Joe's son
hunter scored a lucrative position on
the board of burry SMAW holdings that is
Ukrainian oil and gas giant well hunter
Biden was paid millions of dollars for
consultancy fees but he had no
experience an oil gas energy or no
experience with Ukraine that anybody can
find in November 2015 Joe Biden was told
by the New York Times his son's under
investigation by Ukrainian authorities
December 2015 Joe Biden made his first
request to the president of Ukraine to
fire the leading prosecutor looking into
the investigation of Purisima holdings
and the relationship with hunter Biden
in March 2016 John Solomon reports Biden
knew this prosecutor was again
investigating his son that's when Biden
leveraged your money a billion taxpayer
dollars forced the Ukrainian president
to fire the prosecutor in six hours that
would be a billion reasons why he had to
and Biden claims the prosecutor was
corrupt and that's why he wanted him to
go he wants you to believe the billion
dollar quid pro quo had nothing to do
with the son's company thanks to John
Solomon
breaking news tonight we now have
evidence that Biden is likely lying
through his teeth